what is the one rule of men the one rule
of men is very similar to the one rule
of Fight Club the first rule of Fight
Club is you don't talk about Fight Club
and the first rule of men the one rule
of men is that you don't talk about what
it's like to be a man specifically a man
who is suffering or struggling so if
you're having a hard time the rule is
don't talk about it I think that that's
one of the main things that I see a lot
of men battling against you know they've
sort of been compressed underneath this
rule for a long time what it leads to is
some type of rock bottom and I think a
lot of men are convinced that things
aren't actually going to change until
they bottom out because there's nowhere
else to go when your version of strength
is I have to suppress my anger my
anxiety my sadness my grief and you've
been told that if you can push things
down long enough that you will somehow
be stronger it creates a very strong
part of you that is actively working
against you